we don't realize the the ripple effect
that we have sometimes so I just came
from Montclair Saint University out in
Jersey
yeah Claire University or whatever um
there's a couple there's a kid that came
up to me and you know when I was trying
to lose weight I was doing it for myself
right and then I just put out a few
videos like a couple videos talking
about it and speaking about it the end
goal of that wasn't really for everybody
else it was more for me and if something
somebody took away something for me it
was great but there was a kid who lost
like 80 pounds what the [ __ ] you know
that's like half of me and there was
another person - that was talking about
how like I did this I guess this kid
actually went to a Q&A that I did a a
while back mmm somewhere else and then
they took that advice and they came to
this college to see me when I was in
Jersey and they weren't in college at
the time but they decided to go into
film because of what I did and I said
well why did you go into film because it
wasn't because like I am a film guy it
was just more like that was something
that I was passionate about and I kept
on trying to chase what everybody else
thought that was that was good for me I
decided to do what I want to because of
one you you did and I said oh [ __ ] like
there we definitely do have this ripple
effects um yes like it's not gonna reach
everybody yeah but when it does reach
somebody it's very nice yeah I'm you
know when we get this advice to us
because it's not because we know
everything it's just we understand what
it's like to be in your shoe yep so you
basically we're talking to our younger
self yes 100 us all it is it's like a
therapy session yeah cuz it so it's
almost like like you say like we're
challenging ourselves but we're just
putting it out there and it's a reminder
for us - yeah and in its it's almost
like we're just documenting and journal
journaling our thoughts out loud like
like this like this whole talk like what
I was thinking five years ago is not
what I think today oh you know 100% and
it but we let it we just put it out
there we just put it out there and
people see the evolution or they see the
change and I think from that it's kind
of like an example of maybe if they were
in that mindset - what things can be so
like let's say if you're 20 years old
right and then you watch a video of mine
of
I used to work how I used to look what I
had materialists like like like success
level wise like if you just measure
money-wise or whatever where I was at to
where I am today like they go oh wow it
is possible and I'm not that different
from Joe you know Joe was actually in a
shittier place it goes maybe I can do it
right and I mean like I think the
byproduct is inspiration but I'm not an
inspiration seller like we're not
motivational speakers you're not like
we're not the Tony Robbins and things
like that although I like those kind of
things but that's not who we are we're
just talking about life and just being
who we are so I don't know what the [ __ ]
we do but whatever it is that sometimes
the the side effect and it's a good side
effect is people get inspired by that
and I'm like that's [ __ ] awesome just
like change through osmosis or something
like when we did the little workout
clinic that you oh yeah oh yeah yeah
that that was crazy because you know I
knew we were gonna get a bunch of people
like I did wasn't expecting how many
people without really interested in
coming out cuz this is I'm not from that
world right so I'm coming from a
completely outside perspective and like
to see how much you guys how much reach
you guys have is one thing but then to
actually see it in person and to hear
these people talk about how like man I
watch your videos every day and they're
like being emotional and they're really
like pouring their heart and soul out to
you yeah and I'm sure it's the same
thing with you too I haven't seen the
first hand but I'm sure it happens to
you all the time messages diems but it's
kind of crazy to see how people respond
to you and how much information they
take from a video you may put up that
you may not think that yeah it's gonna
help anybody really but you see it
increases tenfold and all the comments I
see on your videos are like oh my god
young me lose so much way about you
inspire me to do this and to see it
firsthand is like a completely different
animal in itself and I'm just I was
sitting there with Jason while we were
kind of [ __ ] around but like what
while we're hearing you talking we hear
everyone talk like we were like holy
[ __ ] this is this is a different animal
completely and to hear how much you guys
impact these people on daily life it's
like your jaw drops
you really have no perspective we could
like I said I get shocked by it too you
know I get shocked even more when
they're like when a guy comes up to me
or a girl like this was one dude he came
up this guy was jacked he goes dude
you're my inspiration I was like dude
how [ __ ] dare you look better than me
you're my inspiration I was a [ __ ]
there's some muscles huh yeah okay how
dare you take my advice and then one-up
me you son of a [ __ ]